>> I'm going to put in a
password.  Submit, save, and
I'm a new balance rewards
member
Balance Rewards member.  So very
, very cool.
Again, it's as simple as
tapping in a Walgreens terminal
in
order to use this Balance Re
wards card.  We made it very,
very simple and available to
all merchants as well.  Let's
go and try to complete this
purchase here and show you what
the experience looks like.
So we have here a terminal,
can we switch to this.
Yeah.  We have here a terminal.
This is a actual Walgreens
terminal.
We're going to show you what
it's like to make a
purchase of one of these really
nice like almonds.  Turns
out it normally costs $5.99.
Can you just focus in a
little bit close er on it so
you can actually see the charge?
Okay.  So I think you
notice it, right.  It's $5.99,
except that that's just the
regular price.  If you have a
Balance cap rewards
Rewards card you get a price
break on this, which
is very cool, saves you money.
I'm going to show you how
easy it is to use your Balance
Rewards card with Android
Pay.  I don't have to open the
app, I don't have to open
Android Pay to use it, et
cetera.  I'm just going to tap
(
(ding) and I've transferred my
Balance Rewards card.  That
simple.  I've got a price break
and the new price is $3.99,
and it completes the purchase.
All I have to do is tap
again, transfer my Amex and the
purchase is done.  Okay.
(Applause)
this experience, so look
forward to sees more merchants
integrate to this experience
so you can engage your
customers better and your
customers
get to save money.
So with that, I want to
hand it over to Sridhar
>> SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
Thank you, Pali.  These are
some amazing demos again.  Of
course, we wanted to make
sure that we did something for
small and medium-size ed
merchants as well.  So we work
with Square to make
available for a limited time to
qualified retailors a free
contact list reader as well as
a discounted payment
process
processing on all Android Pay
transactions.  We want to
make sure that all merchants
get benefit that consumers use
Android Pay to pay.
I want to touch on
something really, really
important
important.  It's the last
portion of our talk, but it's
super critical.  It hits many
of the points that I talked
about early ier.  It's clear
that financial institutions, the
debit, all of these relation
relationships with, need to
play an active role in move ing
the mobile payment ecosystem
forward.
And when we envisioned
Android Pay, we create ed APIs
that these banks could use to
bring the payment experience
right within their app.  Why is
this a big deal?  Because
there is a lot of detail to
implementing a great payment
experience.  And they could
integrate it right into their
app, save ing themselves a lot
of implementation headaches,
security headaches, and of
course, time, which is the most
important current cy.
And they do that, then
they're free to innovate on
what else they offer their
consumers.  These banks are
often the ones that know us
best.  They're the ones that
are observe ing our
transactions.  They are the ones
that we
have relationships with.  We
think this will drive a lot of
innovation in how mobile
payments are brought out to
consumers.
So we are very please ed
that a number of banks, both
in the U.S. and abroad, are
working with us to integrate
Android Pay directly into their
app.  We think this will
drive more innovation and
provide more flexibility for
consumers.  We think of this as
a win/win for Android,
Android Pay, and for, you know,
these banks, and, of course
course, consumers as well.
And with that, now I want
to thank all of you, our
developer partners,s in
bringing this Android story
forward
forward.  Without us working
together, there is not going
to be a lot of involunteer
innovation, and so
we really look to working
with you to improve the way
mobile payments work and for us
to get passed the which bay is
doing what, and more to
mobile payments just work in a
way that is expected and
convenient for all of us.
So thanks to all of you
for helping us realize this
vision of Android Pay being
everywhere in mobile app, in
physical stores, in mobile web
as well.
So Pali and I have barely
touched on the surface of
topics that can literally take
days of discussion.  You're
going to be having lots of
break-out sessions over the next
after this session, right
here, so please come to those,
ask us lots of questions,
there will be folks       folks
from the payments team in all
of these
breakouts sessions.  We look
forward to talking with you
and really helping bring this
vision of Android Pay to the
large er role.  With that,
thank you all for coming..
next section, we are going to
dive into the latest and great
est feature for accessibility in
Android, and we had a lot of
very exciting things to share
with you.
The first one is vision setting
on the welcome screen.  This
will enable visual impaired
users to independently set up
their device.  Now, can we
switch, please, to the
Dem?  This is the main screen,
the welcome screen on Android.
Here at the bottom we have
vision settings that flashes
every ten seconds.
if I tap on that, I'm presented
a couple of options.  I have
magnification gesture, font size
, display size, talkback.  For
example, I can select
magnification gesture and then I
can triple tap and I can
increase the size and magnify
the UU.
Now           UI.  The other
ption I want to
option I want to highlight is
display size.  This is a new
feature launched in Android.  If
this is the regular screen
size     size, I can increase
the size of the overall UI.  to
be bigger.  The nice thing about
all those settings, that
whatever settings I'm selecting
it's going to be reflected both
through all the welcome screen,
but also as the user setting
throughout the device.
Back to the slides
. feature is monoaudio support.
This one is intended for people
who have a hearing loss in one
ear.  This enabled them to
listen to monoaudio stream, and
we do that by combining the left
and right channel into a single
mono audio stream. have a
couple of new features in talk
back including improved tutorial
clarity, improved gesture
detection to work better across
different devices and hardware,
and also we added a new API for
accessibility service to turn
themselves off.  So if the user
accidentally turn on talkback
talkback on the
welcome screen, it can easily
turn it off.
Now, the next section is about
the gesture dispatch API.  This
is something that I'm personally
very excited about it, because
now we will allow app developer
to build services such as points
scanning, face tracker and eye
tracker.  For the next one, I'd
like to invite Anna, a engineer
on accessibility team to demo
the APIs.)
.
>> Thanks, Maya. I'm Anna, I'll
tell but the new gesture
dispatcher API, accessibility
services, touching the screen.
First of all, what is a touch?
It has three parts.  Placing a
fink other the
finger on the screen, drawing a
gesture and lifting the finger.
The new API letle you
let's you as a developer
specify the middle portion, the
path taken by a imaginary finger
or fingers.  Why is this
important for accessibility?
Take a look at switch access, a
accessibility service that does
not assume that you can touch
the screen.  Rather, it lets you
use a switch or set of switches
to move across actionable views
and select the currently
highlighted view.
This leaves off functionality,
when you don't want to interact
with the entire view, but rather
a small part of it.  The
example that I'll be using is
Google Maps, specifically the
maps area which supports complex
gestures, things like zooming
in and out, and padding the
advice ab area.
the visible area.  With
this API we can add point
scanning to switch access and
that lets us perform complex
gestures.  Let's look at how we
can use one switch, to operate
Google Maps.
We will start in the maps app.
You notice I have a switch
already connected to my dives
device.  I'd like to get
walking directions to the three
buildings just west of here.  I
don't quite remember what they
are called.  But fortunately,
once we make a selection on the
map, we can get directions that
way.  Here it seems like I don't
see those three buildings on
the map.  I'll have to pan to
get to see them.
I'll start point scanning by
pressing the switch.  The first
thing I'll do now is select
where I want to perform that
gesture        gesture.  First
the white coordinate
Y coordinate and
then the X coordinate.  Here
I'll choose to swipe right.
Now at the lower left, we see
the three buildings that I'd
like to walk to.  I'm going to
place a pin there by pressing,
I'll start by choosing the
location first.  Starting with
the Y coordinate again, and then
the X coordinate, and here I'll
choose long press from the
actions menu.
This gives me a button at the
bottom of the screen, asking
whether I'd like walking
directions.  As that is exactly
what I want, I'm going to select
that button.  Again, I'll
choose the location first
.  And here I'll choose select.
Here we are.  Directions to the
point we just chose from the
map using just one switch.
I'll hand the mic back to Maya
now who will tell you about
another cool application of the
gesture dispatch API.
(applause)
.
>> MAYA BEN ARI: Thank you, Anna
, for the demo.next demo is an
extremely exciting one, for a
tracker using the dispatcher API
by a company called Sesame
enable, a Israeli company that
was cofounded by two people,
Beau Ded, computer vision
expert, and Giora who is in high
current engineer who became
quadriplegic due to spinal cord
injury.
enable utilizes the phone camera
of the device to track head
moving, head movements and move
a mouse cursor.  I'd like to
invite Vlad the head of develop.
From sesame Enable on to the
stage to demo the technology.
pplause)
.
How are you doing?
>> Great.
>> MAYA BEN ARI: Ready for this?
The first thing that Vladi
will do is he will, can we move
to the demo?  The first thing he
will do is enable the service.
This can be done through voice,
but because of the acoustics
here, Vladi will just tap on the
sesame Enable notification.
Now, the service will calibrate
Vladi's face, after it lock it
down, he can control a mouse
cursor using only his head.
Now    Now, if Vladi would like
to tap on something, he just
will, and he can tap.
Once he is into his E-mail, he
can swipe up or down.
I think we are a little bit
excited.
(chuckles)
.
It's okay.
Would you like me to help you?
>> You can try.
>> MAYA BEN ARI: Let's try it
out.  The first
here, I'm going to calibrate my
face.
Now I can control the mouse
cursor.  It's hard here because
the overall stage is shaky.  It
is hard.
Yairs can it's              It's
hard to calibrate.  The overall
stage is shaky.  But it's hard
to do.  This is what the demo is
all about.  In general, after
we move the mouse cursor, we can
also clock the sensor, this is
by looking
right -- yeah.  Try again.  Just
go to ... yes, sorry
.
In general, this demo is about
how to use a mouse cursor using
the device, control the mouse
cursor.  It's hard to do it on
stage because the stage is a
little bit shaky.  Let's try it.
)
.
The thing is basically, you can
do everything using a head
tracker on the device including
tapping and touching and
swiping        swiping.  And
also downloading any app from
the play store and basically
interacting with that app only
using your face.
(applause)
.
If you want to try it out, in a
little bit of a less shaky stage
, you are more than welcome to
come out to access
an empathy sandbox to try it
out.  One last note about this
API, that while this API is very
powerful, it doesn't diminish
the need for app developer to
make their app accessible, such
as add    adding content
labeling or increasing touch
target size, because while the
API allows you to interact with
different elements on the
screen, it doesn't know which
element it interacts with.
So following every best
practices, it's still very
important.  So thank you so much
, Vladi, for your help.)
.
With that, I would like to hand
it off to Patrick and Scott to
talk about voice access.
(applause)
.
>> All righty. Thanks, Maya.
I'm Patrick Clary, product
manager on accessibility at
Google.  With me is Scott
Newman, software engineer on
accessibility at Google.
We are here, excited to talk to
you about a new accessibility
service, for Android, called
voice access.  This is an
accessibility service that is
meant for users with a motor
impairment, that find it hard to
use a touch screen with their
hands.
Before I talk about that, I want
to tell you about one of our
testers, whose name is Andy.
Andy is a 65-year-old male, with
a central tremor.  For Andy, he
likes to be able to communicate
with friends and family, and
send them pictures, through
E-mail and messages and updates,
and he generally does this at
home on his desktop PC,
utilizing an app like Dragon
Naturally Speaking which allows
him to dictate by voice.
However, Andy would like to be
able to do this on the go, from
his mobile device.  But due to
his tremor, using a touch screen
is very problematic.  Now if we
take a step back here, we
realize that Andy's experience
is not that unique.  In fact,
there are millions of people in
the U.S. alone that have some
form of motor impairment that
impacts how they can use a touch
screen.
This can range from people with
a central tremor like Andy, to
people who have Parkinson's,
amputees, people with arthritis,
even people with spinal cord
injuries to name a few.
In addition to that, there are
many more people who have what
we call a situational disability
, like Maya mentioned before.
This could be a temporary
impairment that affects their
use of a touch screen.
Something like a broken hand or
wrist, or maybe their hands are
occupied.  A common use case we
hear is that someone might be
cooking and their hands are
dirty, they don't want to use
their hands.  They would love to
be able to still control their
device.
This is the motivation we have
for voice access.  Our goal is
voice access is to provide
someone this complete control of
their device through use of
their voice alone.  In that
sense we want to be able to
allow users to click by voice.
Or to put in the words of one of
our testers, use your voice and
you are able to access the
world.  You might be asking, how
does an accessibility service
like voice access differ from a
voice assistant, like Google Now
or okay Google where you can
say this hot word and then
perform a search query which is
more conversational, or you can
perform a voice action, like you
can set a reminder, you can
create a calendar event.  An
accessibility service is
different.
We are looking to empower people
to be able to use their device
and have full device control.
Now the high level voice
assistant is lacking the fine
grained commands needed to do
this     this.  For example, I
mentioned Jeff likes to send
messages to friends and family.
From his mobile device, if he
wanted to do this, he might have
to open the camera app, take a
photo, by pressing the button,
open a app like Hangouts by
clicking on the icon, scrolling
and swiping to the contact he
wanted, clicking on a attach the
photo and then tapping on the
text box, typing in text and
clicking send.
With voice access our goal is
for each of those touch actions
to enable a corresponding voice
command that allows users to
chain together a series of
commands to perform a complex
task.
To see it in real life, I'll
hand it over to Scott who will
give you guys a demo.
>> SCOTT NEWMAN: Thanks a lot,
Patrick.  My name is Scott
Newman.  I'm a software engineer
on the accessibility team.  I'm
excited to give you a demo of
voice access today.  Before I go
ahead and get started, I wanted
to mention that as some of you
may be aware, speech recognition
demos can be fickle in front of
live audiences.  If you run
into any issues, bear with me,
and we will get through them.,
let's go ahead and get started.
I remember that Patrick sent me
a message a little earlier, and
I'd like to read it.  But
before I read the message, I'm
going to go into accessibility
settings, and enable large text.
It's easier for those people
in the back of the room to see
what is on the screen.
Open settings.  Scroll to the
bottom.  Tap accessibility
.  Tap large
text.  Go home.  Go home.
Let's try one more time.  Go
home.  All right.  There we go.
That is voice access in action.
What actually happened right
there?  You may notice that
there is this persistent blue
button that appears on the top
right of the screen, and so that
is a voice access activation
button, so from any screen, you
press that button and voice
access starts listening, and
then from there, you can issue
commands to globally navigate
the device, experience act
interact with
individual elements on the
screen and control your device
entirely by voice.I did there
was, I opened the settings app
by saying, open settings.  I
said scroll to the bottom, to
scroll the screen down as if I
were performing a traditional
tap gesture.  Then I said, tap
accessibility, to tap the
corresponding button to the
screen that was labeled with the
text accessibility, then I did
the exact same thing to press
the switch labeled large text.
This actually uses the same
accessibility APIs that underlie
the other accessibility
services that we have seen so
far, like talkback or switch
access.  As long as you follow
accessibility development best
practices, your app should work
with voice access right out of
the box., let's actually see the
message that Patrick cents me
sent me.  Can we go
back to the -- thanks.  Open
Hangouts
.  Patrick Clary.  Stop voice
access.
Again, I used voice access to
open the Hangouts app.  When I
said Patrick Clary it actually
found the clickable button to
the screen, with text that was
labeled Patrick Clary, and then
clicked that button to    on my
behalf.  One other thing that
you may notice is that there are
these numbers that are drawn on
the screen, whenever voice
access is actively listening.
What that is, is a safety
fallback.  If you want to
interact with something on the
screen that is clickable or
scrollable, and there is no text
associated with it, let's say
clickable image, then you can
default saying the number and it
will click that element on your
behalf.
With that, I'm going to respond
to Patrick's message. , and then
send it.  Type, the party is at
7.  Actually I notice that I
made a mistake.  The party is I
think at 8 instead of 7.  Let
Let me change that really
quickly.
Replace 7
with 8.  In addition to
navigation, interacting with
individual elements on the
screen, we actually offer a   a
full sweelt of           suite
of text he had        editing
commands.  That is one of many
you can use to Edith text
edit text, replace parts of
text with other text, you can
copy, move elements around
.  It is a fast way to interact
with whatever is on the current
screen, and the Hangouts app
didn't need to do anything
special to work with voice
access.  It works right out of
the box.
What I'm going to do now is send
the message.  You will notice
that at the bottom right of the
screen is a green send button.
There is no text associated with
it.  In order to click that
button, I'm going to reactivate
voice access.  I'm going to say
the number that is associated
with it that appears right next
to the button.  It's going to
click that button and send the
message.
Let's go ahead and do that.  Tap
11.  Stop voice access
.  Undo.  Stop voice access
.  So, that is voice access for
you.  Notice that you can start
voice access by pressing this
blue button.  Actually if you
want to do it completely hands-
free, if you say the Okay Google
command, there is another way
that you can access it,
completely hands-free by voice.
We offer a whole host of
activation methods, so you can
choose what is most efficient
for you.  Similarly, you can
stop voice access by saying,
stop voice access or by touching
the screen, which is a
fail-safe option to leave voice
access quickly.
That is voice access in
practice.  Can we go back to the
deck     deck, please?  Thanks.
Let's hear from some actual
voice access users about how
it's impacted their lives.  Roll
video, please.
>> My name is Stefanie. I just
finished my masters in
advertising.  I'm a C4, C5 split
level quadriplegic, I have no
feeling from my collarbone down.
So it is absolutely vital that
I'm able to use my voice.  Okay
Google, start voice access.
>> My name is Jeff. I have a
neurological condition called
the central tremor.  It is
incredibly difficult to use my
hands and fingers.  It is very
easy for me to use my voice.
Okay Google.  Start voice
access. this product for
probably about ten seconds, I
think I'm falling in love with
it.  Open camera.  Use your
voice and you are able to access
the world.  Shutter, share,
Hangouts
, Astrid Weber, send.
>> I cannot tell you how excited
I am about this product.  Open
calendar, new.
When you don't have the ability
to use your fingers and hands
hands, family movie night.
It's really all about voice.
(applause)
.
>> That is voice access. We are
really excited for you to try
it out.  It is in open beta now.
If you come to the access and
empathy sandbox area, you can
try it out yourself.  With that
I'm going to hand it over to
Astrid and Jennifer Kozenski
Devins to talk about how you can
use research to    for the
quality of your product with a
case study.  Thanks a lot.
>> Thank you, Scott. Hi, my
name is Jennifer Kozenski Devins
and this is Astrid.  We are
inclusive design and researchers
in Google.  We wanted to share
with you today a little bit
about how UX research influenced
and drove the design of voice
access.
First, what is UX research?  The
general definition is that it
focuses on understanding user
behaviors, needs, motivations,
through observation techniques,
task analysis and other
methodology ies.  The key is
that while we might think we
know what users want because
maybe we are users of our own
products, or maybe we are close
to it and develop and design it,
it is critical to get out there
and get feedback from external
users and understand their
unique perspectives, insights,
challenges and pain points.
In fact, the products that we
demo'd here today all underwent
many iterations of design and
development, and all of
which were inspired and driven
by UX research.
The process itself is about a
five-step process.  It can be
cyclical, if you want to keep
refining.  The way it was
applied to voice access, it was
first looking at what are the
objectives of the product as a
whole?  One key objective of
voice access was that they
wanted to ensure it was easy to
use, easy to learn how to use,
right out of the box, in a hands
-free manner.
From there they developed
hypotheses, okay.  So based on
that objective, they thought
that contextual help was the
best way to allow people to
learn how to use the product in
the moment., they define what
the best methodologies were to
use, conducted the research,
synthesize ed those findings and
reported those back to the team
, which further iterated on the
design of the products.
Now Astrid is going to take you
through the specific
methodologies used and how those
insights actually impacted the
design of voice access.
>> ASTRID WEBER:
Thank you, Jen, I'm Astrid
Weber, UX researcher working on
voice access.  I'd like to show
you how we accompanied the
design and development process
with a few research
methodologies.  I'd like to get
started with formative research.
Formative research is, if you
go into the field in order to
understand about your users from
the daily lives, so you go and
see how they work, how they live
their lives at home.  We worked
with users with severe motor
impair        impairments as you
saw before in the video.  What
we learned is that at the moment
there is no cohesive strategy
for people who can't use their
hands in order to access their
mobile devices completely hands-
hands-free. knew that, we
went back and developed the
first prototype of voice access.
As soon as we had something
that was testable, we did test
it.  We did so with internal
testing.  Internal testing is
probably best known to tech
companies because all you need
is yourself.  All of us within
the team installed the
application, people outside the
team, and we tried to use it in
as many circumstances and
contexts as possible.
What we found was a lot of bugs.
We addressed those bugs.  We
made the product better.  We
iterated it, until we got to the
point that we felt the product
is so stable now that we can
actually put it in front of real
users.
RAW COPY
Present:  AND OTHERS
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO  80132
1-877-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
***
This is being provided in a
rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) or
captioning are provided in
order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
record of the proceedings.
***
we did.  We ran usability
studies.  Usability studies are
when you invite people to
actually come into your lab,
those are people from the core
audience or in our case, people
with severe motor impairments.
They test it.  You are in front
of them, you can see exactly
what they are doing.  They are
running through a couple of
tasks with you.  You see the
limitations of the product.  You
see where it's failing, but you
also see where people are
especially delighted, and what
you see in the picture is one of
our labs.  It is designed to be
comfortable and welcome ing to
our users, and at the same time
it has cameras to capture audio
and video.fterwards, we can
actually go back into the data,
analyze and see exactly how we
can improve the product.
Usability studies are great, but
they have limitations.  I think
the biggest limitation is that
it's a very short period of time
that the user is interacting
with the product.  It's in the
lab environments.  So it's not
their real life.  We went one
step further and conducted diary
studies.  Diary studies as the
name already indicates, are
studies where the user is going
to keep a diary about their
usage.  What did we do?
We sent voice access home with
the users on their personal
devices, installed, and they
could use it in whichever
context they wanted to.  The
only thing they had to do, they
had to promise us that they
would report back about the
experience.  You can do that
over the phone.  You can have
them write E-mails or fill in a
quick survey.  In the end of the
study, they will come back into
the office with us, and give us
their report, how they used the
product, what they liked, what
they didn't like.
What we learned from that
process is that for one voice
access really needs to be
polished and be visually delight
ful.  You have seen in the video
the latest design that we have.
We didn't start off on that.
I have a few more examples on
that in a minute for you.
The second thing, if you use it
on the go, you need a really
easy way to activate and
deactivate it, because otherwise
it's too much hassle for the
user to actually dive into the
software and then again when you
don't want it to deactivate it.
Let me show you examples that I
mentioned.  The first one that I
would like to talk about is how
we improved the contextual help
.  You       You see on the left
side the before and on the
right side you see the after.
What is that?  On the left-hand
side we see a long list of all
the voice commands that we are
offering.  Everyone who is using
or developing on voice based
software knows that the biggest
challenge is how can you teach a
user what they can say and how
can they remember that?
It is essential that we are
offering a place where the user
can go back and check again what
they can say in order to get to
a specific result.  We thought
it makes sense to offer one long
list, everything in one place,
people will find their way.
When we observed them in
usability studies, we found this
is actually not the case.
People got lost along the long
list, they even forgot what they
were looking for because they
were so overwhelmed by all the
stuff that we offer in there.
Also the way we presented the
information without any examples
was not intuitive to understand
for them.
What did we do?  We see on the
right side the first screen shot
, we had categories now.  We
have basics of navigation,
gestures and text editing.  With
those, the users deep dive into
a smaller subset of commands,
which you see on the next screen
shot with basics of navigation
that the user gets specific
examples of the voice action
that they can take.  By doing
so, we actually had much better
results that users were able to
find what they were saying and
also for remembering later on
where to find that command again
.
The second example I'd
like to show to you is our
tutorial.  Again, having a
really good tutorial is crucial,
especially if people have not
used voice interactions before,
in order to navigate the
interface.
We wanted to make it as real as
possible, so we took a screen
shot of the interface and
explained it to the users.  What
we didn't expect was that users
would want to interact with the
screen shot and wouldn't
distinguish between a screen
shot versus the real product.
the learning back, and redesign
the experience, as you see it on
the right-hand side, to be text
, explaining the functionality,
so this is how to use the
numbers, what had been done
before and we did have numbers
now on the screen but those are
real.  So you can interact with
them.  The user is learning
about it immediately and they
can apply the learning, and with
that we actually made really
good progress.
Now, Jen is going to talk about
usability testing and how you
can use it for your own
application.
>> JENNIFER KOZENSKI DEVINS:
Thanks, Astrid.  In the few
minutes remaining, we wanted to
leave you with a quick starter
guide of how to do your own
usability studies because we
find them very effective.
anything fancy to actually
execute these.  Usability
testing is useful to understand
how people use your product, and
why.  That is the key point, is
the why.  Before you jump in
and just bring somebody in and
have them run through some tests
, you want to have a plan and a
strategy.  First start
starting with what are the key
questions you want to answer
with this research?  Write this
these down, refer you them
with the team, make sure
everyone is on the same page.
These are your research
questions.  Without solid
research questions, the end
result might not be
might not meet everybody's
expectations.
Based on these questions, you
will identify tasks that will
help you answer these questions.
For example, if a question was
was, are users able to
onboard without any additional
assistance           assistance,
you would bring in the new user
and have them start the app for
the first time, and maybe run
through some of your key
fundamental tasks, and see if
they can do it without asking
for assistance from you, looking
in the help or on-line. happy
with your study and your test
questions and tasks, you want to
think about who to bring in and
actually conduct the study on.
You can certainly start with
friends and family.  Ideally
those people will actually be
using your product or do use it.
We also highly recommend
having a diverse set of
participants, as much as
possible.  You can reach out to
various organizations that lobby
for accessibility needs and
they are more than willing to
accommodate you and get people
to help run the study on.
When it comes to actually
running it, figuring out where
to run this, you don't need a
fancy lab like we showed.  You
can find a quiet comfortable
space, and you want to make sure
that there is room in there for
yourself, the participant
obviously, ideally you will have
somebody to help take notes,
and you will have some video
recording equipment, and also
it's great to have a developer,
designer, somebody that is very
close to the product there to
observe as well.
There's been tons of books
written on how to do, actually
conduct usability studies
effectively.  They all kind of
boil it down to these four key
steps.  Asking the users to
perform the test, and then
taking a step back and observing
them, seeing what are they
actually doing, other than
completing the task, are they
hovering in interesting spots,
are they using a keyboard, what
keyboard certain         short
cuts are they using.  And that
leads to the next point, digging
into why.  You were hovering
over the button.  Can you tell
me why, what did you expect to
happen or after they complete a
task, did that meet your
expectations?  This is the magic
of use     use ability studies,
being able to understand the
rationale and meaning behind
behaviors.
Most challenge ing part of this,
especially if you are close to
the product, is remaining
neutral.  You might have the
urge to want to defend or
explain, we tried this but
couldn't do this, we tried this,
this is not the time to do that
.  You are there to listen,
absorb the feedback, and move on
.  Oh, and then practice.
Definitely practice, at least
once, before bringing in real
users. study, you want to ensure
that you write down the most
interesting findings right away.
And then review those findings
with your team after each
participant.  This will greatly
help at the end summarizing your
findings.
If you have the ability to
videotape it, cut small video
snip      snippets to help
support your findings.  Not
everybody will have been there
with you observing the study.
When you are present
presenting your findings, you
can show, look, this is how the
users actually interacted with
the app.
Then one of the most critical
pieces is, it would be a real
shame to do all of this work and
have it just sit in a doc
somewhere unused.  You want to
have somebody in charge ready to
drive the process to address
these issues.  Of course it
doesn't have to happen right
then and there.  But you want to
be sure that somebody is taking
the charge to prioritize and
figure out what are bugs, what
are feature requests, and when
they will be addressed.
We have on our, on the I/O app
and our spaces a great link to
give you more details on how to
conduct usability studies if you
are interested.  Overall, we
hope that you found that this
brief overview of the research
methodologies used for
Voice Access inspiring.
Hopefully, you can bring it back
to your team.  Back to Patrick
now.
(applause)
.
>> PATRICK CLARY: Thanks. Thank
you, everyone, for attending
attending.  So you know,
as you can see, it's very
important for us to hear from
users with accessibility needs,
so that we can learn how to
improve the platform, and for
all of our developers to take
into account Android development
best practices, so we can all
make apps that are great for
everyone, who has different
accessibility needs.
So, if you would like to try out
voice access it's in beta now.
You can sign up for the beta,
at G.CO/voice access.  List
Listed on the screen are other
talks we are doing that are
accessibility related.  Please
attend those.  They are all
great      great.  Come visit
our sandbox.  It is access and
empathy, it's right over that
way.  You can go there to do a
demo of voice access.  You can
go see the demo of the sesame
head tracking, learn about many
more things and also attend our
code lab.
Thank you, everyone.  Take care.
(applause)
.
(end of session at 3:45 p.m. P
T)
(Please stand by for the VR
VRfive session on stage
1,
Introducing Project Tango Area
Learning.)
(Please stand by for the VR
5 session on Stage
1,
Introducing Project Tango Area
Learning.)
VR
VR5 session, Introducing
Project Tango Area Learning.)
(Please stand by for the
session to begin.)
GoogleGoogle I/O
2016, VR5,
Introducing Project Tango Area
Learning.)
(Music playing.)
>> WIM MEEUSSEN: Hey!
Hello, everybody.  We have a
full house.
(Applause.)
>> WIM MEEUSSEN: Thank you
all for coming.  Welcome to
this talk about Project tango
and Area learning.  My name is
Wim Meeussen and I lead the
project location team.  Today I
one of the core technologies of
Project tango.  It is at the
foundation of everything we are
something I deeply care about
and it's exciting that today I
can spend the whole session on
Area learning.  If you have no
idea what Area learning is,
that's okay, we'll cover that
in this talk.
So let's get started with an
So number one, by the end of
this talk you will be able to
build an augmented reality
application where you can put
virtual objects in the world
and they will stay in place and
you have built AR applications
before, you know this is a real
really big deal.  I'll have a
live demo where I'm show you
how I place these objects and
how they stay in place in the
environment.
Number two, by the end of
this session you will know how
to build multiplayer experience
experiences where multiple
Tango devices interact with
each other.  This is obviously
without any wiring, without any
environment.  Just works with
just your mobile device.  And
finally we'll talk about some
future applications where you
can imagine that you never get
lost anymore in large buildings
buildings.  So I always like to
start out with a quick poll to
get a little bit more
background about you.  By raise
of hands, how many of you have
heard about Project tango
before today?
All right, that's most
people.  How many people know
about Area learning?
That's just a handsful.  How
many of you are here because it
it's really hot outside?
(Laughter.)
>> WIM MEEUSSEN: A few
honest people.  All right.  So
today I really want you to come
of what Area learning is.  Like
how it works and also how you
can use Area learning to build
new applications and enable new
user experiences.  So I'll
start out with a quick high
level overview of what Project
Tango is, for those of you
still new to Tango.  So
fundamentally Tango is about
enableing mobile devices to
understand the world around
them.  So Tango uses computer
vision for your device to be
understand the geometry of the
world but also to know its own
position and orientation in
that world.  In some sense it
turns your screen into an
extension of the real world.
Your screen becomes this magic
window into the real world.
And if you look at the
example here, think about this
device if it understands what
the world around it looks like.
some interesting contents about
about the world.  Imagine you
can display directions on how
to get from A to B, or you
could display virtual furniture
from all different angles to
see how it would fit.  You can
imagine you can have a game
that just plays out right in
your living room.
Tango can enable a whole new
simply were I am impossible
before.
So let's look at the three
main technologies of Project
Tango.  There is ocean tracking
tracking, depth perception and
Area learning.  If you have
attended talks about Tango
before, you've probably heard a
lot about the first two.  Today
we'll mostly focus on the third
one, Area learning.  Let's do a
quick overview for all three of
them.  Motion tracking is all
about allowing your device to
know how it moves through the
world.  So as a developer you
can use motion tracking to know
how your device moved relative
to where it started.  So if,
for example, I start here and I
move 1 meter, I can ask the
motion tracking component how
far I moved relative to the
start.  If I move back to the
original place I can ask motion
tracking where I am and it will
tell me I'm back where I start
started.
So motion tracking is all
about allowing developers to
ask the device how it is moving
through space.  Then depth
perception.  So every Tango
enableed device or every Tango
phone has a special 3D camera.
device can sense the 3D
geometry of the world around it
it.  So if I point my device at
the speaker desk here it could
sense kind of this geometry at
the front of the desk.  If I
point it at the back of the
desk it would sense the
geometry at the back of the
desk.  Wherever I point it it
can sense the 3D geometry.  As
a developer you can query that
3D information in the 3D .
clouds.
So then the last core
technology Area learning, this
is what really gives your Tango
in a very similar way to how
people operate in the real
world.  Remember when you came
into this dome or tent thing,
probably in the back of your
head you started building up a
model of what the space looked
like.  You saw a speaker desk,
there's two big screens, there
there's a lot of chairs.  And
you take that mental model and
you store it in your memory.
So imagine now if you would
leave the room.  Say you go to
the restroom.  When you come
back later you would quickly
recognize that you're in the
same space because you
recognize the desk and the
screens and the chairs.  You
would recognize that you are
back in that same space.
And Tango Area learning
works in a very similar way.
So when you bring a Tango
device into a new space it will
world and compute this
mathematical description of
what the world looks like and
it will store that mathematical
When you then bring that same
Tango device in the same room
at a later time it will be able
to compare what it sees with
its camera to that mathematical
memory.  When those two match
up it recognizes the space and
it knows exactly where it is in
that space.
So let's dive a little deep
deeper into the details of how
Area learning works and even
how Tango works under the hood.
So Tango has this wide angle
the world.  It is much like
this example when you are
visiting a mall, your Tango
device will look at a few key
landmarks it cease in the world
world.  For example here on the
machine in front of you.  There
There's some restrooms and then
So now what happens when you
start moving in this
environment and you keep look
looking at those same landmarks
landmarks.  What happens is you
sudden in different places in
your field of view.  So for
example if you look at that
vending machine, initially it
was on your left side.  As you
move, at the end the vending
machine is almost right in
front of you.  And this is
exactly how Tango motion
tracking works.  Tango will
look at all these landmarks in
the world and see how they move
that motion it can compute its
own motion in space.
So this is pure motion
tracking.  This is still all
without any memory.  So in this
example, if you are in the mall
mall, if you cover your eyes,
spin around and open your eyes
again, you would have no idea
where you are because you
didn't have any memory of that
space.  The same, every time
you start Tango motion tracking
tracking, it doesn't have any
memory.  So it always starts
from scratch.
So let's now think about
what if we add memory to this.
So for a Tango device it
doesn't need to remember the
entire image of what it sees.
It only needs to remember the
key landmarks that it's track
tracking.  In this case it
would look at a small square
patch, like the yellow squares
around each landmark to store
kind of a mathematical
description of what exactly
that landmark looks like.  Your
Tango will store two things in
memory.  One is where it saw
that landmark, and the second
is that mathematical
description of what that
landmark looks like.  This is
how Tango can remember its
space.
So let's jump to a live demo
demo.  So you can actually see
how this works under the hood.
So I'll
first just start up
Tango motion tracking.  Here if
the screen you get to see how
Tango is looking at the world.
landmarks that Tango is seeing
and that Tango is tracking.
Instead of looking at two or
three or four points in the
world, Tango can look at 100
points at the same time.
As I move, Tango keeps track
of how all those landmarks kind
of move in the image.  If you
then look at the right-hand
side of the screen it's a top-
top-down view of where I am.
If I walk in a big circle here
you can see that motion
tracking knows exactly that I
walked in that circle and that
I ended up back where I started
started.
So this is motion tracking
under the hood.
Let's now jump to area
learning.
So initially this
looks very similar.  You just
have Tango looking out into the
world, but now Tango is actual
actually building up a memory
of what the space looks like.
Once it has created a memory,
as has happened now, you see
all these static yellow dots.
Those are the landmarks that
Tango has remembered.  I can go
physical points in the world
that Tango has stored in its
memory.
On the right-hand side you
see these lines coming out of
the device.  That is showing
where Tango recognizes a
landmark that it has stored in
its memory.
Now we can do something real
really cool.  Say I cover the
cameras here.  My device has no
it learned, you can see all
those landmarks popped back
into place.  It actually
remembered where it was based
on that memory.  Let me do that
one more time.
So now it doesn't know where
it is.  And then you see it
jump and all the yellow dots
are back in place.
(Applause.)
>> WIM MEEUSSEN: It's
pretty cool, right?
So this is really a view
under the hood of how Tango
operates for both motion
tracking and for area learning.
So now let's look a little
bit at how we can use area
learning.  You have a pretty
good understanding of how it
works.  Let's see, what can it
go for you.  What kind of new
experiences can area learning
enable?
And let's first cover kind
of an AR example.  So let's say
want to see how it fits.  The
problem you're having here is
that that chair will start
drifting over time.  And that
is because if you just have
motion tracking you will have
very small errors that slowly
accumulate over time.  And if
you walk around enough your
chair might look something like
and drift.  But this is exactly
the problem everyone wants
solved with Area learning.  You
right there.  The way area
learning can help here, it can
build up a memory of where you
placed that chair in the world.
exactly you placed that chair.
So even though if motion
tracking slowly drifts, because
placed that chair it can always
correct it and put the chair
right back in the right place.
And I'll have a live demo of
this coming up a little later.
It's actually pretty cool to
see.
So there's obviously a
number of other AR based
examples.  Let's say you are
using the 3D sensor to start
measuring the geometry of your
world.  If you have these nice
yellow annotations on your
world, you want them to stay
exactly in the right place.
You don't want them to start
drifting around.  This is again
where area learning can help.
And even if you have an
example where your objects are
in static, like, for example,
you have these monsters running
around, you still do care that
your virtual world and your
real world stay aligned with
each other.  If you would start
monsters would start running to
the shelving and you want them
to stay in the center aisle.
You do care about that
alignment.  Again area learning
jump to the second kind of big
use case.  That is multiplayer
experiences.
So the problem here is
pretty obvious.  You want to
know where all the other player
players are in the world.  And
it would be awesome if you can
do it without needing to put in
capables
capable cables or
infrastructure in your
environment.  How can area
learning help here?  So the key
for multiplayer experience is
to have a memory of your space
and to share that memory
between all the devices.  When
all your devices have the same
memory, here this is the
display of what your device
could have memorized.  If all
your devices share that memory,
they can all start recognizing
where they are in that space.
And in some sense you turn the
real world in your kind of way
to tie all these Tango devices
together.  You don't need any
special infrastructure.  You're
using your couch, your carpet,
the poster on the wall.  They
literally tie together this
multiplayer experience.
So let's look a little bit
at how this actually turns out
in the real world.  The real
world is always a little bit
more messy.  Give a number of
examples where Tango will have
some challenges with area
learning.  It will give you a
bit of a better understanding
of where to best apply area
learning.
So if you look at these two
images here, the left side
could be what your room usually
probably what you want your
room to look like.  If you and
me look at these images we can
kind of recognize it's probably
the same shelves, there's hang
hangers that you recognize.
Pretty sure, same place.
But for a Tango device those
different spaces because Tango
has built up all these landmark
landmarks on top of the clothes
and
everywhere.  If all the clothes
move, the landmarks moved and
Tango would get confused.
Imagine you are walking around
San Francisco and you are look
looking at some of the big
skyscrapers to keep yourself
oriented and someone comes in
and moves all the skyscrapers
around.  You would be pretty
lost.  This is what happens to
Tango when stuff in the
environment moves a lot.
So here is an example where
things didn't move, but one
image was taken in the day and
one at night.  Even though your
differently because of the
lighting, because of shadows.
And something that everyone
has played with cameras will
probably recognize, if you have
a dark room and a really really
bright
window you have troubles with
your exposure.  You need to
tune in on the window or the
room but you cannot have it
both ways.  This should be
pretty obvious.  If you have
large crowds they can make a
space look very differently.
Then another kind of extreme
example, Tango looks for visual
visually interesting things in
the world.  If your room is all
is nothing visually interesting
interesting.  There's no
landmarks for Tango to
recognize.  If you go outside
you can imagine a lot more
different scenes, weather,
shadows, the outside gets a
little more challenging.
So the question is:  How do
you deal with all these
challenges?  And the key point
here is time.  Like if you look
we talked about, those happen
slowly over time.  And in some
environments will change quick
quickly and some will change
very slowly.  You can imagine a
museum that has the same
exhibition year-round and has
maybe constant lighting.  There
your memory will be good for
months and months at a time.
At the other extreme of the
scale you can imagine a subway
station with lots of people
running around, maybe there's
advertisements that change.  So
there your memory would be
valid for a lot shorter of a
time.
So a really good strategy to
short-term memory.  So if you
think about your AR application
furniture in your house, maybe
you want to look at it for 20,
30 minutes.  But then during
those 30 minutes your house is
not going to change.  So you're
good there.
But if you want to play a
multiplayer game in your living
room, maybe you want to play
for a couple hours.  During
that time the living room is
still going to be your living
room.  So if you rely on short
shorter term memory, area
learning could be a powerful
and reliable tool
.
So let's get to the -- oh,
let's actually play this video.
So this is a real world example
of area learning being used.
This video was recorded in the
Zurich train station.  And if
you look at the video, you can
see a lot of the challenges
that we just talked about.
There's some outdoors or some
shadows that you see.  There's
people walking around.  You can
see the floors are kind of one
color.  But then still area
learning can actually work in
this environment.
So area learning can be
pretty robust through a number
of these changes.  The examples
I showed were extreme to drive
the point home but you can see
how it actually operates in the
real world.
Now, I'll go a little
further in this video because
there's actually something cool
because Tango fully works in 3D
3D.  You can actually go
downstairs and it will tell you
in full three dimensions where
you are in the world.
So let's look a little bit
at how to build an application
with area learning.  Again I'll
cover two examples.  I'll have
the AR example with drift
correction and I'll have the
multiplayer example.
So first one, you want to
use memory here to keep all
your virtual objects exactly in
the same place.  So this is
kind of where area learning
will help you build this.  And
for this example, I will assume
you have an application that
uses AR, and I'll tell you how
to transition it to area
learning.  If you don't yet
know how to build an AR
application, Friday morning,
there is an interesting talk
about how to build a full AR
end-to-end example using Tango.
So if you're interested in that
that, definitely go check out
that talk.
Here I would assume you have
area learning.  And the point
of this light is just to show
you it is really easy.  You
need to change literally two
lines of code.
In the first highlighted
line, you just tell Tango
please enable drift correction.
tell Tango instead of measuring
where your device is relative
to where you started, measure
it relative to this memory that
we'll build up.  With just
those two lines you can
transition an app from regular
AR to area learning AR.
Let me show you a demo of
how that works.
So I'll show the same app
first without area learning and
So this is a little AR app
that allows me to place a real
really large cube on top of
things.  So we are not using
area learning, but the cube is
pretty, it stays in place
reasonably well.  But now we
have a little bit more, I move
around.  You can see it is
still more or less there.  If I
some point I will lose my cube.
It just doesn't remember
anymore where it is.
So let's now do the exact
same thing with area learning
enableed.  So now in the
background Tango is actually
building up that memory of what
the speaker desk looks like.
So now let me place the cube
back.  So now we can do the
same thing.  I can shake the
device, if I look back as soon
as it recognizes the space, it
can put the cube back exactly
in the right place.
I can do my example where I
cover the camera, let the app
get completely lost.  And when
I open it back, as soon as it
recognizes it it can put the
cube back in exactly the right
place.  So you can have
applications where your virtual
are, even if your session break
breaks, even if your user does
something crazy, the virtual
objects will stay in the same
place.
(Applause.)
>> WIM MEEUSSEN: So let's
jump to the next example.  How
do we build a multiplayer game?
So this is a little bit more
involved.  It includes three
different steps.  So first we
will create a memory of, let's
say your living room.  Then we
will share that memory with all
your game.  So let's first
thing about how do you create
that memory?  So what that
means in your shared space, you
code in Tango?  Very simple,
you tell Tango start learning
the area.  Then when you're
done, you say "save."
Then you have built up a
memory of what that space looks
devices?  Again, pretty simple.
Tango has an export and import
functionality.  So you can
export your memory from one
device and import it on all the
So once you have all your
devices set up, you are ready
to go play.  So what area
learning has done or what the
building of that memory has
done is created this one
reference frame that can be
used by all the different
devices.  Because that entire
memory is all reference from
like one frame in your
environment.
So every single device in
your multiplayer game can
directly ask Tango:  Where am I
relative to this memory?  If
you have multiple devices using
get their reference relative to
the same reference frame.
And this is how you run that
Tango please use this memory
and then you start asking Tango
Tango:  Where are you relative
to this memory?
So the code all looks pretty
simple.  So now I want to share
a video.  I want to introduce
the video a little because I
think it's easy to under
appreciate the awesomeness of
the video.  So the setting is
exactly this picture here.  So
we have three players that have
a Tango device non-front of
their face.  So they are
completely in a virtual world.
They can not see each other.
And the video you are going to
see is showing that virtual
world of what one of the player
players is seeing.
And one of the key things
you should look out for, in
that video you will see a Tango
virtual Tango device because it
is a virtual world.  But that
device is actually exactly a
match on a real device that's
in the real world.  You'll see
different players hand that
device to each other.  So think
virtual world.  Only if they
know exactly where all the
other players are, they know
exactly where that device is,
only then can they do this
comfortable hand-off.  It's
pretty amazing.  Check it out.
So this is filmed from the
third person.  Even the third
person is moving around.  You
see how the other two are just
casually handing off the Tango
device from one to the other.
So this is only possible with
registration between all those
different components.  You have
two players.  You have the
person filming it.  And then
the Tango device.  You have
four different devices tightly
coordinated with each other.
So pretty amazing.
(Applause.)
>> WIM MEEUSSEN: Then this
is an example of kind of using
VR.  If you want to try
something like this for
yourself, are tomorrow night in
the Project Tango after hours
we have an AR multiplayer game
set up.  You can go try it out.
And also if you want to just
try Tango demos, the sandbox is
of cool stuff going on.
Not that now that I'm
advertising
a couple of things, there's two
Tomorrow at 3:00 p.m., Johnny
Lee will be talking about
everything that is new within
Tango.  Definitely go check it
out.  Then on Friday, Friday
morning A hunk will be talking
about how to build an AR
application.  Two more exciting
What's next for Tango?  And
what's next for area learning?
So I hope by seeing the demo
demos you have been wondering:
everything you see until now
will be part of our release
coming out next month.  So yeah
...
(Applause.)
>> WIM MEEUSSEN: You will
be able to build these drift-
drift-free, drift-corrected AR
experiences.  You will be able
to build multiplayer experience
experiences.  And this release
is just a beginning for area
learning.  The Tango team will
keep improving and we'll keep
building better and more robust
very beginning.  As developers
you are getting a very early
preview on what area learning
can do.
This is the start of what
will become a pretty exciting
journey.  So let's take a
little look at where this
journey could take us next.
Let's look at future
applications.
So here imagine you are
wrist it
visiting a mall and you're
trying to figure out where you
are in that mall.  You pop out
your phone, you start up Google
Maps and you see something like
the image on the left.  You get
a nice floor plan of the mall
and you see the big blue circle
somewhere here, but we don't
know quite exactly where.
Imagine what you can do with
area learning.  Imagine if your
where it is in that mall.  You
could pinpoint your location.
And your experience could look
a lot like the image on the
right side where you have an
exact location, you even know
exactly which direction you're
facing.
And if you take this one
step further, if you combine
the very accurate location with
augmented reality, you can
imagine that you can get really
really
accurate directions on how to
get from where you are to, let
let's say, your favorite store
in the mall.  Like all augment
augmented in the real world.
So I hope this gives you
some idea of where area
learning can take us in the
future and you realize we're
just at the very beginning of
what this technology can do.
Then obviously we are not
only at the very beginning of
technologies like area learning
learning.  We are also at the
very beginning of the Tango
device ecosystem.  So you've
all seen the Yellowstone device
devices which is our developer
kit.  There's thousands of
those in the mands of developer
developers out in the world.
Now Tango has partnered up with
releasing the first consumer-
consumer-facing Tango-enableed
phone.  It will becoming out
later this year as a worldwide
launch.
(Applause.)
>> WIM MEEUSSEN: So I hope,
like I said, I want to end with
this.  I hope you realize this
is actually a great and amazing
lot of new technologies coming
out.  There's new devices
coming out.  I think we really
have this unique opportunity to
with their phones.  Even how
phones interact with the world.
So I'm pretty excited to see
what we can build together.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
(Music playing.)
(The session concluded.)
***
This text is being provided
in a rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
RAW COPY
Present:  AND OTHERS
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO  80132
1-877-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
***
This is being provided in a
rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) or
captioning are provided in
order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
record of the proceedings.
***
(Please stand by for the CL7
session How to Build a Smark
RasPi Bot with Cloud Vision and
(Please stand by for the CL7
session:  How to Build a Smart
RasPi Bot with Cloud Vision and
***
(Please stand by for the CL7
Smart RasPi Bot with Cloud
Vision and Speech API.)
(Please stand by for the
session How to Build a Smart
RasPi Bot with Cloud Vision and
Speech API.)
>> Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for attending this
session.  We will be with you
and starting this program in
just a few moments.  Thank you
for your patience.
(Music playing.)
>> KAZ SATO: Hello. Thank
you for taking your time for
our session, How to Build a
Smart RasPi Bot with Cloud
Vision and Speech API I'm Kaz
sato, I am with Google Cloud
Platform Glen I'm Glen Shires,
a software engineer on the
Cloud speech API.
>> KAZ SATO: I would like
to show a demonstration video
of Cloud Vision at first.  Let
me share the video.
>> Provides powerful
capabilityies as easy to use
API
APIs.  It enables application
developers to build the next
generation of, that can see the
that power several services.
The service enables developers
to detect abroad set of
attitudes within an image from
every day objects to faces.
The service is so easy to use.
cases, you can have any RasPi
pi robot like GoPiGo calling
the application directly.  The
ball can send the images taken
by the camera to the Cloud and
get analysis results in
realtime.  It takes spaces in
the image along with the
associateed emotions.  The
Cloud
Vision API is able to detect
entityies within the image.
Now
let's see how facial
discrimination works.  Cloud
Vision detects faces on the
picture and returns the
position of eyes, nose, and
mouth.  You can program the bot
to follow the face.
(Mechanicaldigital sound.)
>> It detects emotion such
as joy, anger, surprise, sorrow
sorrow.  The ball can move
towards smiling faces or avoid
anger or surprised face.
>> One of the very interest
interesting interest
interesting features of Cloud
Vision API is the detection.
It detects any object you like.
(Digital voice:  It's glass
glasses, it's awfnlt.)
>> Hmm. (Digital voice: It
It's money.)
>> Cloud Vision would like
developers to take advantage of
website to learn more.
>> KAZ SATO: That was the
demonstration vision video for
Cloud
Vision bots.  I would like to
discuss how to build the bot by
talking about the intelligence
working behind the bot.
>> GLEN SHIRES: Thank you.
>> KAZ SATO: So we are
using technology called nerual
networks.  What is nerual
network?  Nerual network is a
function that can allow from
the training data set.  It
mimics the human brain by using
example if you want to do
recognitions with nerual
networks, then you can converge
your input image such as cat
images into a large vector and
then put that vector to the
nerual networks where it does a
as multiplications or additions
between vectors and matrixes.
Eventually you have another
large vector as an output which
represents the levels of the
objects detected such as the
cat or automobile or the human
face.
So let's take a look at
another example, how nerual
networks works, nerual network
works by using the data set
called double spiral.  In this
double spiral data set we have
two groups of the data points.
One is the orange group.  And
another is food group.  If you
have a -- if you are a program
programmer and asked to
classify those data points,
what kind of program code would
want many N statements or sweet
statements to classify the
points, each location with the
points by using the condition
and the thresholds?  Do you
want to write that?  I don't
want to write that kind of code
code.  Instead I would be yug
maximum likelihood weds for --
using machine learning to write
those.  Let's take a look at
this demonstration.
This is a demonstration
called play ground where you
can just actually run the
nerual networks to solve this
problem.  Now you are seeing
the computer is trying to find
the optimal combination of the
parameters inside nerual
networks to solve this problem.
Actually it is not working
right.  Let's try again.
Sometimes the machine learning
fails.  So you have to try
multiple times.
Here you go.  The computer
found a way to combine the
parameters in away to do the
classification with the double
spiral data sets.  This is how
nerual networks work to solve
your problem rather than
instructing the computers how
to solve the problem by humans.
Okay.  Robot is right.  You
can apply this nerual network
technologies to solve the much
more complex problem such as
recognizing a cat image or
experience walking around the
street.  You can do that, but
you have to have many more
delays, layers inside the input
vector and output vector.  So
it takes a long time to retrain
retrain.  That is called deep
nps or deep learnings, but the
largest problems right now for
deep neural networks is the
computation resource.  It
usually takes like a few days
or a few weeks sometimes to
finish your trainings with deep
So that's the reason why
Google has been researching on
Distributed Training by using
Google Cloud, by using the GPUs
training time in order of one-
one-tenth or one-hundredth.
That's the reason why Google
has been so successful on apply
applying the deep neural
network technologies to the
many consumer services such as
the voice recognition with
Android devices or the image
recognitions with Google Porter
Porters or the running in the
Google search services.
Now we have over 20
production services in Google
that has been using deep learn
learning technologies
underlying.  And now we have
started to externalize the
power of the neural networks
running on Google Cloud to
external developers.  The first
product is called Cloud Vision
API and the second product is
called Cloud speech API.
What is Cloud zigs API?
Cloud Vision API is an image
analysis service that provides
a pretrained model.  You don't
have to train your own neural
networks or machine learning
model.  Rather than that, you
can just use the rift API,
uploading your own images to
the API and you will be
receiving the analysis result
in a JSON format in a few
seconds.  You don't have to
have any machine learning skill
set or experience.
And it is so inexpensive, it
takes no charge to start trying
out the API.
So let's look at another
demonstration for Cloud Vision
API.
Here I'm launching a
demonstration called Cloud
Vision exploreer which we have
imported over 80,000 images
from wiki media and applied the
analysis already and by using
the result of the Vision API we
so you are seeing the cluster
of the images such as C cluster
cluster, snow cluster or area
cluster.
And if you take a look at
the cluster for cat, then you
will be seeing many images that
is classifyied as a cat like
this.
If you put this next to the
API, the API will be sending
back the results such as the
cat or pet or this must be a
British short hair.  All those
results will be returned in
JSON format like this.
But in this demonstration
you can see them in the UI.
Also if your image has a
text inside it, then the API
can convert the text inside the
Three crossing the -- you can
get it as a string.  Or if you
have the faces in your images,
then the API can detect the
faces and locations of each
face and also the emotions of
each face such as joy or sorrow
sorrow, anger or surprise.  So
you can easily find which face
is smiling or not.  If your
image contains a very popular
location, then it can provide
the name of the popular
location such as city field
stadium in New York City.  You
can even put markers on Google
Maps.
Oh, sorry.
(Laughter.)
you can even use
the product detection feature
so you can easily understand
the image has the product
corporate logo.
So that was the
demonstration of the Vision API
API.
So let's take a look at how
you can bring this machine
intelligence into the bot.
Cloud Vision bot is based on a
RasPi product called GoPiGo.
That is by Dexter Industries.
You can gone and by GoPiGo for
around $200.  You might want to
We have written a few hundred
lines of Python code to capture
the image to the API.
It is really easy to start
getting started with Vision API
API.  You can go to Cloud.
Cloud.Google.comGoogle.com/
Vision to get
started.  You can start the
Quickstart tutorial and that
should be finished in about 30
minutes.
This is a sample of Python
code to send your image data to
the image binaryies into the
base 64 and embed that text
into the content property of
the request.  You have to also
specify the types of features
you want to detect.  In this
case you specify the label
detections of the features so
that you will be receiving the
labels as a result of the API
analysis.  And you can make the
call to the API.  Then you will
be receiving the result JSON in
a few seconds so that you can
easily dig into the JSON result
If you specify face
detection, then you will be
receiving the positions of the
face and the landmarks such as
the bounding properties where
you would have the X and the Y
positions.  And also you will
have the joy likelihood
property where you can find
each face is smiling or not.
So it is really easy to write a
Python code to turn the bot
into the direction with the
face and also if it's smiling,
you can run the motors of the
bot and follow the person.
So let's take a look at the
real demonstration of the
Vision API bot.
So I'm showing
the console
.  This is the user
interface Web console for the
bovment it is showing the
vision it is taking right now.
not.  Must be working, I hope
it's working.
Is it working?  If you put
the cloud -- it is not saying
anything.
It looks like it's not work
working anymore.
Hmm.
Maybe I can try fixing this
stuff so while doing that maybe
I can pass this to him.  Yeah.
>> GLEN SHIRES: So you want
>> KAZ SATO: Yeah.
>> GLEN SHIRES: Okay.
Hi.  So I would also like to
talk about the Cloud Speech API
which is actually a rather new
API.  It was released about a
month and a half ago.  And it
joins a number of speech APIs
that Google has had for quite
some time, quite a number of
years.  You're probably
familiar with the Android
Speech API which allows you to
do text to speech and speech to
phones, tablets, autos, TV, et
cetera.
So that is in Java.  That's
a Java-based API.
There's also the Web Speech
API which is in Chrome, which
is a Javascript based API that
allows you to do speech.  The
Cloud Speech API is a new API
we released that allows you to
put this on any device.  Any
device or server you would like
it very easy and we support
quite a number of languages.
So we made it very easy to
integrate this into all sorts
of different clients and server
servers.
The Cloud Speech API is
powered by Google's machine
learning.  We have a lot of
experience with speech and we
built that all into the API.
So it is the same powerful
engine that you have on Android
Android, you have on Chrome,
you now have available for
whatever project you would like
pretrained.  There's, you do
not have to learn machine learn
learning to specifically use it
it.  You can just get up and
running immediately.  And it
supports over 80 languages and
variants of languages.  It's
got realtime streaming.  And so
is that as I'm talking, the
text is actually coming out
while I'm talking.
What I would like to do is
give you a quick demo of that.
I'm sure you're familiar
with this page which has speech
Speech API.  What I'm doing
here is pulling up a
demonstration page for the
Chrome Web Speech API.  And
make it a little bit bigger
here.  So what I'm going to do,
notice that the words are
coming out.  First they will be
quite sure.  When it's very
cath
confident of the words it turns
them to black.
So you can see as I'm
speaking the words are coming
out and appearing on the screen
screen.  They turn black after
it is very confident of what I
said.
Where is the
presentation?
Okay.  So that's an example
of the realtime streaming that
that's built in.  And we have a
limited preview right now for
which you can sign up and join
and start using the Cloud
Speech API.
Cloud Speech API is actually
two different APIs.  At least
two versions of the same API is
it.  There's a rift API that's
a simple way to use it.  You
can start.  It's as east easy
as
writing a curl commands in JSON
JSON.  Let me show you the rest
everything you need to know to
do the rest API in one slide.
On the left there's a JSON qub
and you can formulate that and
make it more complicated if you
want, add languages, add
different types of ways you
want to process it.  You can
even add context, a new thing
we released.  You can add new
words to the vocabulary, new
phrases.  That's coming out
this week.  You can make it as
complicated as you want.  The
simpleest request would be
exact
exactly that.  There's a couple
where you insert your audio
file or your audio data.
If you look at the bottom
there's a curl command.  Kind
of long but basically all post
posting the content type and
posting to a URL.  So it's
taking the JSON post to the URL
URL.  What you get back is that
response that's on your right.
Again, this is the simpleest
type of response.  If all you
want is one alternative, you
don't want to see multiple
alternatives and interim result
results, you'll get something
that looks just like this.
So like I said, there's
actually two types of APIs.
The other one is remote
procedure call API.  And what
that means is you can do
everything by simply calling
methods in your favorite
language, Java, C++ or the
other languages that are
supported.  You don't have to
worry about the network.  And
it also supports the bi
bidirectional streaming I
mentioned.  As you're talking
you're getting the data back.
So we support quite a number
of languages for the remote
procedure call.  And this is
actually open source.  It's
free and open source.  If there
there's a language that doesn't
appear here, you can certainly
build the source for that
language and actually use it on
any language.
Also it uses HTTPS slash two
two, HTTP 2 secure which allows
you to have some robust bi
bidirectional streaming.
So what I would like to do
is demonstrate this.
Go straight.
"go straight"
.
Stand still.  Thank you
(Laughter.)
>> GLEN SHIRES: Go to sleep
sleep.
Start that over and we'll
see.  Let me move forward.  So
let me show you while we're
waiting for that to reboot
exactly what we are sending
with the RPC calls.  We are
sending initial request.  This
is similar to the JSON that I
showed in the last slide but in
here we are actually using Prot
Proto buffers to send this.  It
It's a very compact format.  In
other words you're not sending
extra bytes over the wire the
way you are with JSON.  You
send your request.  You capture
is on the thread.  We are read
reading a buffer full of audio
and sending that buffer of
audio.
You will see what we are
calling here is on next.  This
is request server on next is
code that is automatically
supplied and you have ten
languages, so that you can keep
Finally you've got the
response which you can be
running on a different thread
because you are sending audio
and receiving data at the same
time.  Again there's an on next
automatically for you, which
provides the data.  In this
case we are printing out the
results of what we are
receiving.
Go forward.
Spin left.
Spin right.  Go back backwards.
Do
a dance.
(Laughter.)
>> GLEN SHIRES: Go to sleep
sleep.
Play dead.  I like that one
too.
(Applause.)
>> GLEN SHIRES: There we
are.  So one thing I wanted to
point out is, it is responding
very quickly.  That's because
it's streaming the speech as
I'm speaking.  It is not going
to capture all the speech and
then wait and send a chunk of
data up.  As I speak, it's
going bidirectional.  That's
why I can do it so quickly.
My clicker is here.  So what
I would like to do is, this is
easier to show than to talk
about.  Let me show this.
These are experimental features
features, I want to say.  What
I showed you to date is what is
Cloud Speech API.  These are
experimental features that will
What time is it in Tokyo?
>> The time in Tokyo, Japan,
is 9:29 a.m.)
>> GLEN SHIRES: How do you
say when is the next train in
French?
>> (Digital voice: French
phrase.)
(Applause.)
>> GLEN SHIRES: Turn on the
table lamp.
>> I'm not sure how to help
with turn on the table lamp.
>> GLEN SHIRES: There we go
go.
Go to sleep.
So as you can see, I've
demonstrated two different
things in that demo.  The first
one is spoken answers.  What
that's doing is as I'm asking
questions it's providing answer
answers.  And the second one is
integrated with if this, then
that.  Which is a way that you
can integrate with all sorts of
different devices.  In this
case I've integrated with a
light module controller.  So
that you can actually actually
set up
your own triggers to do this.
And this is exactly what I did.
There is a Web page that I went
to and I typeed in what I want
ed
to say as triggers, voice
triggers.
Various ways I want to say
it.  And what is going to
respond when I just say that?
And what it does is it goes out
speak that phrase or one of
those phrases, it goes out and
triggers whatever "if" action
you would like to trigger.
(Applause.)
>> GLEN SHIRES: So you want
to go back to yours?
>> KAZ SATO: Yes. I am not
Maybe I can show the console.
Let me try again with the bot.
Yeah, it looks like it's
working.
>> DIGITAL VOICE
:  News,
next slide
(Laughter.)
>> DIGITAL VOICE: How are
you?
>> KAZ SATO: I'm fine.
>> Digital voice: It
startle -- it is goggles.
Hello.
>> KAZ SATO: Not goggles.
>> It's tie, it's ...
>> KAZ SATO: How about this
this?  If you keep smileing, it
What is this?  Can you see
this?  Oh.  Ahh!
(Laughter.)
(Applause.)
(Cheering and applause.)
>> KAZ SATO: Thank you. So
yeah, it works finally.
>> Digital voice ...
>> KAZ SATO: So that was
our demonstration.
(Applause.)
>> GLEN SHIRES: Want to go
back?
>> KAZ SATO: Yeah.
>> GLEN SHIRES: One thing I
failed to mention with the if
triggers, you can actually add
parameters to those triggers.
You can add a number or string
parameter.  You can, for
example, turn a robot to turn
left or steps or degrees.  You
can make the triggers actually
quite interesting.
So we have a number of
resources that you should go
out and take a look at.  The
Cloud vision API and the Cloud
Speech API.  They are ready for
have a number of other sessions
that are coming up that you
might be interested in.  We
have Codelabs that talk about
machine learning.  There's
several machine learning
presentations coming up.  There
There's Cloud office hours, if
you want to learn more about
Cloud and integrateing with the
Cloud APIs.  We have office
hours throughout this next two
days.  And there's the Sandbox.
So thank you very much.
>> KAZ SATO: Thank you.
(Applause.)
(Session concluded.)
***
This text is being provided
in a rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
(Standing by for the
session
Make Shinier, Faster Mobile
Games with Vulkan.)
(Please stand by for the
session Make Shinier, Faster
Mobile Games with Vulkan to
begin.)
ATSC
(Music playing.)
>> HAI NGUYEN: Sorry for
the late start.  There was some
Chrome cast, but thanks for
coming out to listen to me talk
day of Google I/O and hopefully
the excitement hasn't died down
down.  It's the last talk of
the day.  People may be anxious
to get out of here and start
partying.  We are here to talk
about Vulkan.  It's exciting on
my own.  One of my favorite
topics to talk about.  I have
been ask to tone down the
Vulkan talk a little bit
recently.  It may be good or
bad for you.  Let's find out.
Go ahead and jump in.
Vulkan, lots of rules and no
little bit in all of my Vulkan
talks.  I feel it captures the
general spirit of how people
feel about Vulkan right now.
It's a bit of a joke because
Vulkan does bring a lot of good
have a lot of complications
that hopefully this talk will
help address some of it.
So a little bit of
introduction before we continue
continue.  As you can probably
see from the program my name is
Hai.  I'm a technology lead on
Google's R copying code team.
My role on the team is to
explore different technologies
to find out how we can leverage
them for creative work.  Some
of the things that I explore
are things like Vulkan.  How do
you leverage new graphic APIs
for use in applications?
And I started working with
Vulkan about last December, a
few months before the, couple
months before the   2016 launch
launch.  I subsequently ported
all the demos to Vulkan.
Cinder is a C++ creative coding
framework that runs on Android,
Windows, Linux, open source
under the simplifyied license.
good will and OpenGL ES on
mobile.  That's what it is now.
Probably as Vulkan becomes more
possible with the exception of
ofosis and OSS of course.  It
scales from anything from
mobile to desktop to very large
see in Times Square.  Cinder
has been used recently in the
Cloud to generate content.
Vulkan support became available
earlier on Vulkan's launch date
date.  Since Cinder is a coding
used in many cases, the
implementation is very much
ongoing.
So what this talk is not
about, this is an advanced
level talk.  It's not an
introduction to Vulkan.  It is
not a tutorial on Vulkan.  It
is not an in depth examination
of Vulkan.  If you likeed a
real
really good read, quick read on
Vulkan 30 minutes document.
And if you need to see tutorial
tutorials on Vulkan, we have
some tutorials available on the
sit here and do in depth on
Vulkan, it would take about a
month.  Feel free if you have
questions about the topics,
stop me afterwards or find me
afterwards and I'd love to talk
So what this talk is about.
This talk, the Vulkanist talk
is how to get up and going on
Vulkan in a kind of large way.
Not just like writing sample
code, but getting something to
production.  So it assumes that
you know about OpenGL ES.  And
it assumes that you know a
little bit about Vulkan or some
other explicit graphics API
like metal or direct X12.
Since Vulkan is definitely new
there are sharp edges in Vulkan
Vulkan.  I try to point out the
gotchas and why it's important
to pay attention to device
limits and the difference
between mobile -- sorry,
desktop Vulkan and mobile
Vulkan.  There's a short
session on the things to
consider if you are looking for
Again, these are kind of
heavy topics.  If you find me
saying something that is weird
and it's confusing, please find
than happy to clarify them.  So
to establish a baseline between
OpenGL ES and Vulkan, this
question gets asked more than
any other question when it
comes to Vulkan.  Is Vulkan
faster than OpenGL/OpenGL ES?
The answer is yes but not from
a direct port.  Vulkan is new.
If you want to leverage all the
benefits of Vulkan, you have to
change a lot of your code if
not some of your code and
definitely some of your
thinking.  Vulkan on mobile
feature set is comparable to
that of OpenGL ES 3.1.  However
However, it does include
compute geometry and shared
support.  It is explicit API
that is directly, has direct
control of almost every object
in the rendering pipeline.  The
for memory management.  There
are some new concepts that do
come with API.  There are also
things that have similar names,
differently.
So one of the amazing
features that Vulkan supports
is validation layers.  This is
the first time you've heard of
validation layer, essentially
they are a debug tool that
allows -- that lets you figure
out what is happening in the
API.  It is a very dramatic
departure from GL get error.
The general rule of thumb for
validation layers is to turn
them on at the beginning of the
you ship.  They are cross
platform which means the same
code gets used on Android,
Linux and Windows.  One of the
cool aspects of the validation
is this:  It's a function call
back that you can supply to the
validation layers that gets
triggered every time the
validation message gets trigger
triggered.  This is what the
call signature looks like.
This is what a sample body
looks like.  As you can see,
since it is, you can break it
down into whatever granularity
you need based on the
validation criteria.  And if
you are on a platform where you
you can definitely set a break
point on any of these and look
in the call stack to see where
the validation was triggered.
All right.  So let's go deep
deeper with Vulkan.  I am some
friendly reminders before we
start.  If you were beginning
to port from OpenGL ES to
Vulkan, it's good to keep these
very tariff wral.  The first is
the coordinate system.  Vulkan
coordinate system is open right
guard, everything I rendered
was upside down and backwards
and I thought I was doing
something wrong.  I went and
stareed somebody down and asked
why is it upper left.  There
wasn't a clear answer but it
just is.  Memory management
basis.  In OpenGL you didn't
have to handle a lot offal owe
cangss yourself in any.  In
Vulkan you have to handle
allocations yourself.  Buffers,
pools are handled for you, but
script pools are not.  You
still have to point out to
Vulkan what you need.  So the
first Vulkan topic.  Command
buffers.  So command buffers
are one of those things in
OpenGL that you hear a lot
about but you don't have
explicit control over.  In
Vulkan that changes a lot.
They are one of the primary
things that you use to get
pretty much anything done in
Vulkan.  Command buffer has to
be allocated before they are
used.  Command buffers are
allocated from command pools.
They have to to, the command
pools themselves must belong to
be submitted to the same cue
family as the command pool.
And also while you're
submitting, you want to
minimize the number of command
buffers per frame.  When you
hear this, don't just use one.
If you do that, you'll end up
starving the GPU.  I learned by
difficult to try to fit
everything into a single
command buffer.  You do a lot
of code gymnastic.  In order to
buffers, but min minimize them
as
much as possible.
Sharp edges on command
buffers.  One of the terms that
is tossed around a lot with
Vulkan is multithreading.
There is a portion of the API
that is implicitly thread safe
but there are parts that are
not implicitly thread safe.
You can't record to the same
command buffer from multiple
threads but it's fine for you
to record to multiple command
buffers on threads.  You can
take all those command buffers
and kick them over to a single
submission thread and that's
perfectly fine.  If you are
going to do recording from
multiple threads, make sure
that each one of the threads
has access to its own command
pool.
And directly related to
command buffers is cues.  Queue
Queues is again what you hear
about in OpenGL but you don't
quite have control of.  In
Vulkan again it's very
different.  It's important to
understand queues from their
mode of creation.  Queues,
implicitly have to belong to a
queue family.  You know which
queue family they belong to
through the queue family index.
There are a limited number of
queues.  You can find out how
many they support by looking at
queue family properties queue
counts.  We'll get to the queue
second.
If you find yourself in a
configuration where you want to
do both graphics and compute,
you want to do the queue
combine queues over support
operations.  If you are looking
look for a queue family that
supports both.  The primary
reason, at the beginning or
just at the initial port, it
makes things easier to
coordinate.  If you use
multiple queues, you will have
to do synchronization.  That
can be a little bit of a
headache.
When you are working with
queues, it is important that
you if need to order the queue
operations, do it through
synchronization primitives and
avoid QueueWaitIdle in
performance critical code.
There are good legitimate
reasons for using QueueWaitIdle
QueueWaitIdle.  Through
personal experience it caused a
lot of weird bubbles in the
pipeline and installs that I
didn't expect.
Some sharp edges on queues.
Not all queues are universal.
The queue family dictates what
each queue.  Android Notes on
queue, on Android there is at
least one queue to supports
both graphics and computes.
You can present from any queue
on Android.  On desktop you
have to go looking around to
see which queue supports
presentation or not.  This goes
without saying but worth saying
saying, you have to keep kind
of precise counts on queues.
There are devices that only
support one queue.  So if a
device supports one queue, it
only implicitly has one queue
family.  Check the properties
before you create the cues.  If
you create queues that only
supports one queue, you either
get a hang or crash.
Pipelines or pipeline state
objects as some people call
them.  Essentially these are
data structures that control,
that has properties that
control pretty much everything
that happens in the rendering
process.  And they are a fixed
function.  So that means that
once you compile them you can't
really change any of the
properties.  There's a caveat
to that.  What are called
dynamic properties, the dike
properties can be readjusted or
can be adjusted via command
line -- sorry, command buffer
operations.  These include
things like view ports,
scissors or blend constants.
How many pipelines can you have
have?  If you find yourself
having hundreds or thousands of
fine, a typical application may
have that many.  The reason if
you think about it for a moment
moment, the different
combinations of what you have
in your rendering states can
easily create hundreds of
permutations.  If you are
getting to the point where it's
figure out if you're having too
many variations, too many or
too much granularity in your
variations.
You can cache pipelines.  If
it helps speed up the pipeline
creation.  If you, you can also
and you can do this by looking
at your pipeline properties and
select the pipeline.
Excuse me.
All right.
So discriminate sets.
DescriptorSets are one of my
favorite topics in Vulkan.  I
had to spend so much time with
them.  DescriptorSets are
basically how the C++ gives you
a perspective into how the
resource of the share will need
need.  And there is a few
things that that may catch you
off guard about DescriptorSets
and we'll go over that right
now.  They are binding numbers.
You can sparsely populate bind
binding numbers on the
DescriptorSets but keep the gap
gaps small because unused bind
binding numbers still take up
memory.  There also is a max
binding number.  It is not
obvious, but if you try to
assign a binding number of
32,000 most like GPUs won't
support it and the validation
will call it out and tell you
that your binding number is too
big.
There's also a limit on how
many max, DescriptorSets you
can have down at one time.
This will be reported to you by
max bound DescriptorSets.
Right now if you try to bind
more DescriptorSets than your
device supports you'll just get
have to be updated once you
create them.  So the shareer
will know what -- the general
wisdom, you want to group the
DescriptorSets by update
frequency.  You only should
update DescriptorSets that are
changed.  Updating a script set
right.  Sharp edges on
DescriptorSets.  If you, once
you bind the DescriptorSets you
can't do any updates to it
until the next iteration of the
should do that before binding.
So here is the one really
confusing thing that caught me
off guard with binding
DescriptorSets.  This function
vkCMD bind DescriptorSets.
There's a parameter there
called first set.  It wasn't
obvious from the spec what this
meant.  I thought it meant the
index on to the P descriptor
sets which is another parameter
and to give you a better
perspective, this is what it
looks like.  At the bottom you
see the function signature.  So
to this field in your pipeline
layout.  It's a little
confusing because there is
nothing that helps you figure
this out.  Somebody had to
point this out to me.
Essentially what this does, it
aligns the descriptor set
layout you told them you were
going to use, to pass into the
bind DescriptorSets.
If you are running into a
place where you are binding and
getting a crash or binding and
getting fairly unexpected
behavior, make sure these two
parameters align.
FrameBuffers.  So
FrameBuffers in Vulkan are
slightly different than they
are in OpenGL ES.  You can
think of frame buffers in
Vulkan as basically lucid
attachment pools.  They hold
arrays of vkimage views.  The
relationship between frame
buffers and -- is fairly strict
strict.  Subpasss and render
passes refer to index.  There
is no order requirements.  The
attachments in FrameBuffers
must have the same width and
height.  In the general case
you still have to resolve any
multisample attachments to
simple attachment before you
use them in textures.  Not much
mentioned before, inside render
passes refer to the index.  Sub
Subpass dependencyies.  So when
there is, you'll see a data
structure called set pass
dependencyies.  From a high
level perspective what this
data structure does is that it
builds a dependency graph that
you pass into Vulkan to tell
Vulkan the order in which you
want the subpasses to be
processed.  If you don't do
this, some GPUs will process
the subpasses as they see fit.
you want them to be processed
in.
So make sure that when you
are working with subpasses, be
clear and explicit in which
order you want the subpasses if
sorry, the results of the sub
subpass in the next subpass and
you need to use a, let's say
you are on subpass three and
you want to use something from
subpass zero you need to pre
preserve the attachment.  If
you don't it will get destroyed
Further on the subpasses, if
you have subpasses that have
multisample output and you want
to single sample, you can pass
in images into the subpass data
So here is the diagram that
describes the relationship
between subpasses and render in
FrameBuffers.  You can see on
the right the FrameBuffer is a
list and the render pass is
composed of multiple subpasses.
passes.  You can share as many
as you want as long as it's
within the device limits.
All right.  Okay, so these
are, the next two topics, image
layouts and pipeline barriers,
I wish there was more time to
get in depth.  They are
complicated topics.  I will go
over them as best I can.  The
behavior of these of the images
Some GPUs require image transis
transises, others don't.  All
Vulkan positions accept lay out
for all.  You will take a
performance hit if you do that.
best to assume that all GPUs
require specific image layouts
and set your code to handle it
in that way.  They are both
explicit and implicit.  Which
can be used with image barriers
barriers.  They can be rendered
implicitly by render passes.
There's a field inside the sub
subpasses that ask you like
what do you want this to be
once you're done?  You can also
use a validation layers to
correct any image layout errors
validation layers are very fond
of screaming at you every time
there's an image layout layer.
around.
All right, pipeline barriers
barriers, if you use OpenGL,
they can be a little bit terse.
First one, while they do look
complex, they become second
nature with some practice.  The
other thing is there is a
restriction on the, there is a
restriction on pipeline barrier
barriers within render passes.
pass, sorry, a pipeline barrier
within a render pass, the sub
subpass that you are going to
issue the pipeline barrier in
needs to have a denied eans
within itself.  And you do that
just by telling the subpass the
two, the energy index of that
subpass.
And there's only two types
of pipeline barriers you can
issue within a render pass.
That's vkmemory bare and vk
vkimagine barrier.  So a little
bit more advanced on the memory
management.  Since you are
directly responsible for the
allocation and usage of memory,
just like regular old C, you
need to do bounds checking.
Make sure all your bounds are
checked.  If you write out of
bounds, some let you get away
with it.  It creates these
difficult to track down bugs
and red herrings.  It creates a
uniform buffer.  So build some
code around air error checking
to
make sure all your writes are
in boundss.  Flushing is
something that is making its
way back.  After you do any
host writes, make sure to flush
flush.  After you, if you have
command buffer operations that
do a read, all the things that
read depends on must be flushed
takes place.  There is a slight
caveat to the flushing.  If you
allocate a memory with the vk
vkmemory property host parent,
you don't need to flush.
All right, raiderser shadeer
s.
This is the official lack of
Vulkan and it is a lower level
language.  We are using GSL for
offline or online using, the
same shadeer code can be used
on
desktop and mobile.  There is a
Uniform, obviously you have to
use uniform buffers but you
can't have stand alone uniforms
anymore.  Uniforms have to be
within block variables and
sorry, they have to be within
interface blocks.  The layout
are governed by the SDD140
rules.  If you ever used with S
SDG140, it can be comply
complicated.
In Cinder we use shadeer to
extract from the spear B direct
directly.  If that's something
that interests you, come talk
to me afterwards.  It saves us
a lot of headaches.  Whoever is
bindings or between the shadeer
s
and the DescriptorSets, spend
some time understanding how
they relate with the
DescriptorSets and the shadeers
.
There's obviously a natural
relationship but it's really
easy to make an error in one
and kind of ig error r nor that
it may create an error in the
other because you have to keep
them synchronized.
Performance considerations.
self-evident things that we
hopefully all hold to be true
when we are talking about
performance in graphics.
Obviously minimize host GB
transfers especially on mobile.
power.  Reduce round trips on
any reads.  That includes using
specifically try not to starve
the GPU.  When you starve the
GPU the next round of pushing
data to the GPU can easily over
With respect to render loops
the best thing to do is keep
multiple frames in flight with
Vulkan.  I find in Vulkan I
find it to be easier to do than
when I was trying to keep
multiple frames in flight.
With Vulkan you can very
explicitly do this because of
the nature of Vulkan.
So if you have more than one
two, you obviously have to
double buffer the nonstatic
resources.  If you have three,
triple buffer them.  And this
includes things like command
buffers.  That's a good start
starting point if you want to
find out what resources are
backing that particular frame.
Build accompanied dependency
graph back to the resource that
And so insure since you have
multiple frames in flight, you
probably have to handle the
frame rate yourself.  This
takes a little bit of work and
requires both using the Vulkan
sync parameters plus the CPU
side logic.  This is an area
when you do not want to use BK
QueueWaitIdle.  Somebody,
Vulkan function names are hard
to say.  I know I'm screwing
them up.  They are a mouthful
and really long.  I apologize
for that.
All right.  So here is
something that didn't exist in
OpenGL, but may becoming to
OpenGL soon.  Push constants.
If you're looking to do
something quick and there is
something you have to pass
between your code and the shade
shader code, use push contents.
They don't require buffers or
DescriptorSets.  You only push
20 bites at a time.  The
limitation on them is that you
can only have one push for all
shadeer stages per shadeer.
bytes, you can fit two four by
four matrixes in there.  You
have to be clever how you use
them.  This sharp edge, the
size of the offsets must be
multiple four.  That is not
sharp edge, four is the default
If your size in offset is not
four, something went wrong
somewhere else horribly.
But they are really quick
and fast.  Cinder does have a
simple of how to use this.
And here is what they look
like.  It just looks like a
uniform block except where
layout is, it has push constant
constant.
Excuse me.
All right.  So most projects
will probably start on desktop
and go to mobile.  It is, they
are really highly skilled, but
for the rest of us, pretty much
and migrates to mobile.
Vulkan, the API is actually
crazy consistent.  Cinder took
three hours to port from the
desktop to mobile.  The only
thing that required changing
was basically the WSI or
Windows systems integration and
time to port.  But you can
trust that the API is
consistent.
The only other area that is
different is the extensions.
So that's for the API.
Now, the properties are a
different story.  Properties
for the features are very
different from GPU to GPU.  And
image formats or buffer formats
are host visible and what depth
slash stens aisle formats are
supported.  Don't assume that
two devices that may be similar
in capabilityies that they are
Vulkan positions are equal.  I
made that assumption.  I found
it to be completely not true.
So if you must, write a little
tool that queryies the
properties of the devices so it
solidifyies in your head what
the devices are capable of,
since there's not a whole lot
of Vulkan implementations right
that way.  It really helps.
The other thing when you're
porting, have a strategy to
find the best properties for
that particular device.  An
example in Cinder is we have a
function called vkfind best
tensile format.  The reason is,
only 16 to 24 bit integers were
supported.  At minimum you can
use properties that are known
to work across all devices.
All right.  The other thing
that you should be aware of is
three channel format support is
both image and buffer formats.
So again, develop a tool that
generates a device support on
which formats are supported for
the devices.  And if you do, if
you are relying on any data
packing on your vertex for
images and you are using three
dimensional formats right now
you may have to change the the
format that you're using which
leads me to the next point.  If
you are also staging, if you
are also staging transfers
between your source, host data
and GPU data, you may have to
transform the data in the
staging.  An example of this is
On some devices RGB actually
isn't a, RGB8 isn't a visible
host format.  You have to
transfer that RGBA, copy it to
the Vulkan memory as RGBA and
then do the conversion inside
of Vulkan.  The other way to
work around this is to do a
direct copy from buffer to
image using vkimage buffer to
to -- there's a caveat to this
but this does a bit to bit copy
You can basically read your
image into the buffer and dump
it into the image itself.
The desk tensile copyies are
There's a good portion of the
spec that talks about that.
Compressed textures.  So you
should know, I mean, we kind of
all know mostly these days what
formats are supported.  The
thing not to do is, don't
assume it's supported in OpenGL
ES that it will be supported in
Vulkan.  It mate not be.  One
nice thing about Android in
this regard, all Android Vulkan
will support ATSC as well.  And
the desktop support is
essentially the BC formats.
They may have slightly more
complicated names.
Excuse me for one second.
Okay.  So this is the last
part of this, going from
desktop to mobile.  Not to harp
on this too much, but some GPUs
will require very image layout
transitions while others won't.
important point.  I encourage
if you have questions about
this come talk to me.  I can't
say certain things on stage,
but I can give you specific
details if you want to know
more about this.
So pay attention to the
device limits.  This is almost
goes without saying but again
it catches people more often
than not, that most of the
vendors will go above and
beyond in certain areas of the
device limits and not others.
And some device vendors will
just kind of do the minimum.
It is not because one vendor is
the implementation, right?
Don't assume that the same
class of devices have similar
functionality.  They may not.
If you run into any errors,
especially with device limits,
you can use a validation layer
to track them down.
All right.  So that's about
41 Slides of me talking without
And let me fix that right
now.  So I know that the word
games is used in the title of
the talk.  I am not going to
show you engine demos, but I
will show you render demos, and
fact that Vulkan is up and
running and you can do amazing
things with it already.
Hopefully these demos will be
enticeing enough.  Go to the
demos, please.
So this is a simulation that
runs almost entirely on the GPU
GPU.  It is a fox simulation of
essentially the fish simulation
is running on the GPU.  And
there is a Shark that comes in
every now and then and
basically causes the fish to
disperse.  The code for this is
actually open source.  It is a
sample on Cinder if you want to
totally free.
Whoops.  Stay awake.  The
original work was done by my
friend Robert Hodge inwho was
kind enough to donate it as
part of the Vulkan efforts.
The next demo I want to show
you, it is another demo by
Robert and essentially if you
are familiar with NASA's
capture of sun spots, this is
what the images look like.
So Robert wanted to create
something that was a realtime
version of the sun spots.  So
you know, he likes to create
pictures, but it turns out to
be beautiful.  The funny tidbit
about this, somebody -- actual
actually more than a few people
was the actual NASA capture.
So this one unfortunately isn't
talk to me afterwards and I'm
happy to give it to you.  Can
we go to the Slides?
So to wrap things up, if you
implementation, it is at GitHub
slash Cinder/Cinder on the
Vulkan branch.  If you want to
connect with us about Vulkan,
we want to work with you to
make Vulkan successful.  Visit
this URL.  I have 12 minutes
left and I'm more than happy to
take any questions you have
about Vulkan or Cinder.
Okay.  You have to speak up.
I won't be able to hear you.
Yeah?
>>Audience: (Speaker away
from microphone.)
>>Audience: Can you hear me
me?  So my question is, is
Android itself being powered by
Vulkan?
>> It means when they come
back another time, they are in
airplane mode that shell will
load up quickly ...  You can
cache that content so that
entire view is then available
whenever they try accessing it
without a network connection.
Spot on
.
(The session concluded.)
***
This text is being provided
in a rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.